I get approached all the time by
entrepreneurs who say Evan how can I
start my own clothing line it's one of
the hardest industries to break into it
can cost a lot of money take a lot of
time drain all your resources and
there's tons of competition so today I'm
going to share my three tips for anybody
who's now trying to start their own
clothing line hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and my three tips are this
number one find an angle you have to be
different you've got to have something
unique something that nobody else is
doing because it's such a competitive
industry that you're about to break into
that if you're the same as everybody
else if you even close to anybody else
you're going to get lost in the shuffle
you need to make people pay attention to
you and that comes from having unique
clothes and a unique way to promote
yourself you need it to be easy for
people to talk about you say oh yes this
company they're the ones who do blank
what's that blank for you you have to
find that if you can't have your message
clearly communicated in one simple
sentence you're going to lose people
they're going to go somewhere else it's
that cutthroat it's that brutal and
you're going to lose your business so
you have to find that different angle
number two model success whatever you
want to accomplish somebody has already
done it before don't try to figure it
all out yourself it's not going to
happen success leaves clues you just
have to follow them so if you want to
start a fashion company you want to
start your own clothing label look at
people who've done it before and model
their success look at people like
Russell Simmons Calvin Klein giorgio
armani Vera Wang whoever it is people
you look up to people who have done
exactly what you want to do research
their stores it's not hard this
information is online there's books
there's resources there's videos you can
find it the bigger the name is the
easier it is to find out their story and
look at how they got started look at how
Russell Simmons was in your position
look at how he got started he went from
nothing look at how he got his first
order and look at how he built up from
there there's clues there
that will help you succeed follow them
don't try to come up with everything
yourself and the more that you like that
entrepreneur the more you're going to
believe it and the more you're going to
believe in yourself because we get down
on ourselves and we feel like this isn't
going to happen and when you see that
these other successful entrepreneurs all
went through the same thing and they're
no different than you it makes you
realize you can do it too you can have
your own Empire as well if you put the
effort in and you follow their success a
number three is get some experience if
you just jump into a new clothing line
and you've never worked in the business
before you never had your own company
you have limited experience in the
clothing business you have pretty low
chance of being successful and most of
the people who come to me and say I want
to start my own clothing line have never
done anything in business before you
have a chance of working it out but it's
really slim and I don't want you to go
out and take loans from people take
investments from people put your life
savings into this new venture and not
have it work out I want you to have the
best chance of success that you can give
yourself and that's going to come from
getting a little bit of experience know
what you're getting into so whatever
company want to start go find a company
who you want to be like if you want to
start a clothing label don't go look to
Nike don't go look to Calvin Klein now
look to a smaller company look the
company that has 10 to 20 employees a
company you can see yourself being in
the next year or two and go work for
them it doesn't mean you have to get
locked up into a job for ten years being
the rat race to never escape but you're
working to learn you're learning how do
they create their new designs how do
they market it how do they build a team
how do they raise the money for it all
of that is so important and you're going
to learn while getting paid most people
have the hire consultants to help them
with their business you are getting paid
to figure out how to eventually build
your own business and it might mean you
have to take six months or a year or
year and a half or two years working at
this business as long as you feel that
you are learning and you're taking the
new things that will help you stay there
at some point you're going to realize I
tap this out I'm ready now my chance of
success have gone up dramatically
because I have some contacts I had the
experience I know what mistakes not to
make I know what my product is going to
be and how I'm going to promote it if
you take those three simple steps you
dramatically increase your chance of
making this business work so we've got
to find something different find your
unique angle model success of people who
you look up to and then go work for
somebody who's done it before those who
things will save you otherwise you're
likely to follow the path of most people
who start a clothing line you think you
have a great idea you put lots of money
to your design into ordering inventory
and it sits there in your garage or in
your apartment and no sales come in and
then you have to go back and get a job
to pay off the loans that you took out
or to start to replenish some of the
life savings that you drink and I don't
want that for you give yourself the best
chance of success possible and follow
those three simple steps good luck for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
always makes you want to do more for you
and if you like this video and you want
to say something about it or if you have
a question for your business please
leave a comment in the comment section
below I really always love seeing those
come in I always read them every morning
while I have my breakfast so thank you
and I'll see you on the next episode